[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire les jeux olympiques d'hiver
continue de se dérouler à pékin la
france compte religieusement ses
médailles mais les critiques ne
désarment pas contre le régime de vichy
jean ping accusée de perpétuer un
génocide contre le cio qui n'hésitent
pas à confier l'organisation des jeux un
des pays qualifiés de liberticides
l'année prochaine ça sera le qatar où
aura lieu la prochaine coupe du monde de
football qui sera dans le collimateur
puis viendra le tour de paris en 2024
alors les jeux sont-ils mauvais par
nature tous des catastrophes politiques
économiques écologiques ou sociales
faut-il boycotter les jeux 2024 à paris
pour débattre nous avons invité marc
perelman vous êtes enseignant chercheur
en philosophie esthétique à l'université
de paris-x nanterre vous êtes l'auteur
du livre le football une peste
émotionnelle avec jean-marie brohm et de
2024 les jeux olympiques n'ont pas eu
lieu aux éditions du détour vous avez
appelé à boycotter les jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin ce de sotchi les jeux
olympiques de rio la coupe du monde de
football de 2014 au brésil les jeux
olympiques de pékin 2008 où que se
déroulent les jeux ou les coupes du
monde vous êtes pour le boycott est ce
que vous êtes favorable au boycott des
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024 j'aurai
la même position la vraie logique ça
paraît logique voilà boycott boycott
armor engagez vous êtes consultant
international dans les médias on vous
présente comme expert olympique vous
êtes en effet à fin connaisseur des
arcanes du cio vous avez aidé plusieurs
villes et obtenir les jeux et vous avez
ensuite collaboré alors à l'oganisation
vous êtes l'auteur du livre le pari
olympiques de 2024 chance ou malédiction
paru chez vigo vous n'êtes jamais pour
le boycott des jeux hein vous croyez
toujours à l'olympisme
non j'ai l'impression bout et non non je
crois à l'olympisme moderne moderniser
revisiter le boycott as tu as été
inutile tous les boycotts qui auront
lieu non j'avais eu les effets que l'on
voulait donc c'est pas par le boycott
que l'on pourra arrêter les jeux
olympiques il ya que la guerre pour les
arts ou le coc vite ça y est
alors comment sont justement par part
paris 2024 on se souvient que ça a été
attribué en 2010 est à lima à
l'unanimité à la ville de paris est ce
que est ce que c'est bon pour paris
bah oui si on regarde la promesse de la
candidature de paris 2024 c'est de grâce
au jeu la france va transformer la
france weid olympique enfin et grâce à
cet olympia si je peux dire le sport
sera de nouveau à l'école et bien
enseigner il y aura des effets un
héritage fantastique
en ce qui concerne l'organisation
générale aisément chez nous en ce qui
concerne les images et ainsi de suite
oui ça petit bonne chose mais il faut
t'il encore assumer cette promesse hélas
cette promesse repose sur un certain
nombre de points d'interrogation est-ce
que économiquement ils vont être
responsable parce que le 7 milliards
dont on parle aujourd'hui vont ils être
9-10-11 ce que d'aucuns prétendent
éventuellement est ce que les 11
milliards qu'on a promis pour les 15 1
et 11 milliards des faits en emploi en
augmentation du pib ou avoir les effets
escomptés comme personne n'évalue ce qui
se passe après les jeux peut y avoir un
doute de ce côté là moi je pense que
l'occasion est unique dans les
circonstances actuelles que la france
peut peut-être montrer que l'on peut
repenser les jeux olympiques que de
manière correcte mais encore faut-il le
vouloir marc perelman
m'écouter paris 2024 c'était une
victoire sans concurrence de fait madame
hidalgo qui est une excellente
comédienne par ailleurs été ému aux
larmes d'apprendre par hasard que
c'était paris on a vu la cérémonie
c'était en septembre 2020 2010 s'élève à
lima c'était carrément au poignant et
ridicule à la fois elle pleurait à
chaudes larmes alors qu'elle savait
pertinemment qu'il n'y avait plus que
paris en lice et que los angeles moyens
ans sans doute un chèque sans doute
assez conséquent avait accepté un par
amitié sûrement de replacer les corriger
et figues et par qui d'après vous
écoutez le ceo les cio à des chéquiers
je pense en faisait pas mal quand même
non et donc voilà donc la chose et les
choses étaient réglées avant alors il ya
un vote qu'on peut voir d'ailleurs
encore à la télévision qui était assez
drôle hein normalement tout sauf à
bulletin secret là c'était à main levée
dans une espèce de de fori de choses
très démocratique et paris du coup là du
coup l'a emporté j'allais dire haut la
main mais alors bon pour le reste si
vous voulez bon c'est à chaque fois la
même chose on nous raconte que ça va
être merveilleux que ça va être magique
que sanaa est extraordinaire
que paris va être transformé ce qui est
impossible on voit déjà voilà et qu'il
faut s'attendre qu'il faut s'attendre
vraiment il ya une pure une pure
merveille on s'aperçoit quand même que
contrairement à ce que dit mon collègue
on s'aperçoit quand même que les jeux
olympiques régulièrement régulièrement
le coût des jeux olympiques sont
régulièrement dépassées on avait fait le
calcul plusieurs plusieurs institutions
ont fait le calcul c'est plus de 150%
enfin voila c'est régulièrement des
dépassé et quoique paris nous annonce
qu'on ne dépassera pas j'ai déjà lu
c'est passé ya pas plus d'un mois j'ai
déjà lu que l'assemblée nationale avait
voté modification avait voté une
modification avec la possibilité
d'augmenter de 3 milliards le budget
initial de 2 7 milliards et que c'était
prévu jusque fin de 2020 100 employés
déjà on n'est plus trop sûr de ce qu'on
nous avait assuré un c'est à dire qu' il
n'y aura pas de dépassement déjà on
prévoit
au niveau de l'assemblée nationale on
prévoit déjà le dépassement ça c'est sur
l'aspect si vous voulez financier de la
chose voir le coût va exploser
et d'ailleurs une des gestionnaires de
paris enfin la gestionnaire de paris est
une est une gestionnaire tout à fait
conséquente à madame hidalgo
rui rui in paris dont on sait que la
dette s'élève précisément à 7 milliards
tient comme les chiffres us s'arrête là
dessus sur l'économie on verra après
tous les autres aspects est ce que dit
mark hallman qu'en ce qui concerne la
comédie de lima de devis de d'octobre
2010 est donc dû septembre 2010 2017 bon
c'était évident tout sur tout était
écrit avant la mort puisqu'il ya eu un
accord qui était totalement transparent
le cio faisait un chèque de 1 milliard
200 ou 300 millions pour los angeles et
accepte et 2028 et puis paris avait 2024
alors s'il faut bien comprendre dans le
cadre de cette de 7,7 cette comédie il y
avait au départ sept villes candidates
elles sont tous désistés ligne vers les
autres les tomates barre dans sa malice
le président du cio avait considéré
qu'il est grand temps de cligner plus de
frustrés au moment de l'élection donc la
diff ré attribuées les deux les cubes al
katebat hui ce qui est tout à fait
contraire à toutes les règles existent
et celui d'auto moto cross de masse bar
s'est assis sur les règles l'attribution
des jeux donc ils ont été attribués et
puis ce qui est très intéressant et
c'est là où marque peut être intéressant
parce que le voile luxe alors moi je le
vois de l'intérieur ce qu'il ya tout un
débat de savoir est-ce qu'il était plus
intéressant d'avoir 2024 ou 2028 moi je
faisais partie des gens qui sont parmi
les thuriféraires en quelque sorte des
jeux olympiques revisité et tout ça je
lisais mais c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant 2028 parce que nous sommes
battus pour voir des jeux virtuels
digitaux et ainsi de suite il souhaite
beaucoup moins compliqué que de 1024 non
2024 pour des raisons le centenaire des
jeux de 1924 coubertin et machins et
tout ça a voulu que ce soit du 24 heures
plus dans l'agenda politique c'était
quand même intéressant pour une âme et
diego donc ça cette comédie elle était
prévu le chèque était payé par le cio
moi je pense qu'à terme los angeles sera
vainqueur des situations définitivement
le plan économique la deuxième chose non
au niveau du budget
corps au départ le budget est de 6
milliards 3 ok il y menant de 7
milliards cent alors il ya une moitié
qui sont les infrastructures l'autre
moitié c'est l'organisation d'événements
proprement dite d'oka dont faisait
partir disant c'est totalement
sous-évalué
dès le départ j'avais dit qu'on serait
plus près 10 milliards que 2,7 milliards
sensuelle et des pans entiers du budget
qui n'avait pas du tout été prévu la
sécurité le coût des fonctionnaires et
d'autres éléments qui ne sont pas dans
le budget dudit de la candidature ni
l'organisation mais attention marque pas
je pense que je reste confiant parce que
il ya ce qu'on appelle une opération de
revoyure qui va avoir lieu là après les
jeux après les présidentielles où là on
va mettre tout sur la table et là on
verra ce qu'on va dire à deux ans des
jeux et marc a parfaitement raison tous
les jeux la moyenne du dépassement était
de 176 % en moyenne pour les jeux d'été
je parle même pas des jeux d'hiver à
sotchi
candidature 5 milliards de dollars à
l'arrivée 50 milliards de dollars je
parle pas de pékin jeux d'été au départ
8 milliards à l'arrivée 32 milliards je
parle même pas des jeux de pékin qui
sont là ce n'est pas la peine le jeu de
tokyo 4 milliards de corps à la
candidature 2020 avant l'histoire du coc
vide ou non était à 20 on est redescendu
le coville a rajouté 3 4 milliards le
report ou si on en est à 15 milliards 16
milliards donc ça explose toujours mais
là je pense que le contribuable
regardera si effectivement les jeux le
coût des jeux sera cela qui sera prévu
normalement peut se modifier la cour les
combats s'en mêler l'assemblée nationale
va s'en mêler
beaucoup de politiques vont s'en mêler
et puis je pense qu'on va se pencher
aussi sur leur héritage si effectivement
la promesse qui a fait que tout le monde
des bonbons halal et je regarde ça de
manière à exercer l'art ou pas toute
façon hors ya un problème il ya un
problème il faut bien dire les jeux
ça doit être considérée comme un
investissement et non pas comme ils le
dépensent malheureusement dis pas que
cet investissement parce qu'on est
incapable de dire quelle va être à leur
tour et que le côté voilà le seuil où
mark hallman quand vous en parler on
voit bien que vous les trouvez louche le
comité international olympique elle
reste que ce sont les chantres et les
gardiens de l'idéal olympique dans la
devise je le rappelle est plus vite plus
haut plus fort ça changeait la douche
savonnée together to get her say situe
cents us fortus comme unitaire c'est
ensemble en sang d'hugo d'accord au
parisien
ou alors est-ce que c'est une mafia qui
se vend au plus offrant et qui met les
villes ensuite en coupe réglée
assez drôle d'instance très opaque
pour ceux qui essayent de percer
justement les brumes
du lac léman puisque le sait où se
trouve à lausanne c'est très opaque
c'est très opaque on sait pas trop
comment ça fonctionne alors il ya ce qui
est dit officiellement évidemment un ce
qui est dit officiellement c'est que
tout l'argent enfin 90 % de l'argent qui
est récupéré et redistribuer etc etc
vers les fédérations pour le sport etc
ça c'est qu'ils ont la parole officielle
bon quand on se penche un petit peu plus
attentivement à cancon dc10 ondes de
mettre à jour un peu ce qui se passe
réellement peut-être que c'est un peu
différent tous les cas il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de prévarication de concussion
au sein même du cio et c'est une c'est
la sainte famille olympique 1 qui lave
son linge sale voyez en famille souvent
1 donc on vide des pans entiers du seuil
où les remplace par des nouveaux etc etc
le cio est une instance très curieuse 1
c'est le parlement c'est l'instance
gouvernementale sont des gens qui sont
cooptés donc dans la fin début du 20e
siècle c'était
petite série d'aristocrates qui étaient
là et puis progressivement les jeux
olympiques se développant sa dette c'est
devenu vraiment une structure très
importante un plus de 100 centaine de
membres les aristocrates sous un peu
passé à côté maintenant c'est plutôt des
professionnels qui venait d'ailleurs
d'anciens sportifs jean claude killy et
d'autres qui sont devenus des
businessman a maintenant et donc le
seuil haut c'est vraiment une instance
sur laquelle ils sont enfin sur laquelle
il faudrait vraiment réfléchir quant à
savoir quelle est sa fonction ça qui
m'intéresse à sa fonction socio
politique réelle voyez dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui faut savoir par exemple un
je vous l'apprends peut-être que le cio
est devenu au niveau de l'onu le site
était venu au niveau de mener un
observateur permanent en 2009 ce qui est
quand même pas rien comme statut
et puis aussi parce qu'en 2014
le cio et le sport ont été déclarées
autonome un cirque aujourd'hui le seiu
vraiment ne dépend pas des états et les
athlètes non plus ne dépendent pas des
états alors que vous voyez auparavant on
pouvait par exemple interdire aux
athlètes des états pouvaient leur
interdire d'aller de se rendre à tel ou
tel pays aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
possible ils ont de fait d'une autonomie
garantie en quelque sorte par le voilà
donc le cio c'est une étrange
organisation cas étaient souvent
gouverné par des gens peu recommandables
un man baillet latour
monsieur ça m'arrange anciens franquiste
ancien ministre des sports de franco on
peut retrouver des photos de ce monsieur
avec le bras tendu à l'horizontale
et puis surtout avery brundage le fameux
américains qui s'étaient opposés qui
s'était opposée surtout en 36 au boycott
des jeux olympiques nazis et qui était
lui à vrais nazis isolationniste certes
mais favorable est favorable à hitler et
qui à voile à lutter fermement contre le
boycott des jeux olympiques de 36 alors
que alors qu'il y avait un mouvement
très puissant aux états unis et dans le
monde même en général pour boycotter les
jeux 36 dont on a commencé à
s'apercevoir
voilà qu'il mettait en avant évidemment
le régime que le régime avait comme on
dit instrumentaliser les jeux olympiques
et que pendant les jeux olympiques avant
pendant évidemment après les populations
qui étaient déjà martyrisé en
particulier les juifs n'est pas que les
communistes souvent d'ailleurs les juifs
et les juges communistes à cette époque
les tziganes et autres et bien été tout
simplement été mis en camp et donc les
jeux olympiques de berlin servait tout
simplement de deux paravents de paravent
à ce qui est en train de se passer on a
le même en allemagne même des
déportations des emprises d
emprisonnement et surtout surtout la
préparation militaire de la guerre il
faut savoir que par exemple en février
36 il ya eu les jeux olympiques d'hiver
à garmisch partenkirchen
et juste à la fin des jeux olympiques
d'hiver en mars dont 36 et bien hitler
envahit la rhénanie normalement
démilitarisé et donc les jeux olympiques
d'hiver de 36 comme d'été est vraiment
servi à la préparation de la sq de la
seconde guerre mondiale et toujours
c'est ça qui moi m'inquiète dans les
jeux d'aujourd'hui toujours les jeux
olympiques on était une forme disons de
lieux de préparation à la guerre on le
voit avec ce qui se passe actuellement
avec l'ukraine où les bruits de bottes
sont quand même proche de la frontière
ukrainienne
on voit en particulier aussi avec les
jeux de pékin un ou deux avec les jeux
de pékin le gouvernement chinois
n'hésitent pas à dire que et bien taiwan
doit être reprise manu militari dans
l'est dans les meilleurs délais donc les
jeux olympiques sont toujours un moment
particulier voiliers ou de préparation à
la guerre d'ouverture à la guerre ça
dont il faut se méfier il ya des choses
que j'aurais quand même rectifié marque
si vous permettez
la question était concernant le cio moi
je distingue le cio et les jeux
olympiques volontairement le cio n'est
pas aussi opaque convenait le dire pour
ceux qui l'ont vécue de l'intérieur si
j'en fais partie c'est tout à fait
transparent et on sait ce qui s'y passe
et le cio s'est organisée depuis
coubertin et encore plus depuis ça
m'arrange est un nas barça marenches en
1985 ont été élu président le cio et la
succion faîtière du mouvement olympique
c'est à dire que c'est véritablement
c'est le vatican si je peux dire c'est
que sort sa cour toute cette religion de
l'olympisme et le cio n'est propriétaire
que d'une seule chose les jeux
olympiques qui est une cash machine de
premier ordre
extraordinaire l'argent qui arrange les
droits télévision les droits de
marketing la billetterie la
redistribution et ainsi de suite mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire l'addition
faîtière c'est dire que tout le sport
mondial
est entre les mains suivirent de ces
décideurs et comme il se cooptent entre
eux donc ça fait je dirais de l'auto
l'autoconstruction entre eux
et donc ils dérivent excessivement
importante on sait concerne le bon
fonctionnement du cio ces relations et
fédérations internationales et les
relations avec les athlètes et les
relations avec les comités nationaux
olympiques c'est la première chose donc
c'est la discussion c'est l'institution
faîtière sans laquelle rien ne se passe
deuxièmement ils sont propriétaires des
anneaux olympiques alors là tout est
ouvert les anneaux olympiques bat pierre
de coubertin lui-même que la main sur le
coeur disait oui il faut que ce soit
tout à fait neutre indépendant des états
et ensuite ça du tout depuis toujours
depuis même quand les jeux olympiques
que huit siècle avant l'ère notre ère
d'aujourd'hui lorsque le petit hi-fi
teos
l'a22 clide avait des will claye il
avait décidé de deux derniers voir la
pythie à dire organise des jeux il faut
ça à tout prix parce que ça revenait de
d2 défendre la nation et de donner de
quoi faire au peuple et ça a été
toujours comme ça et là il ya eu une
espèce d'hypocrisie pendant des années
des années en dehors c'est à politique
c'est totalement politique totalement
politique le sport est devenu et le
sport olympique en plus un instrument
majeur de propagande des états à partir
de là vous regardez les états qui
finance en quelque sorte les grands
états qui financent bourg l'apic russie
chine etats unis quelques pays anglo
saxons maintenant des pays du
moyen-orient donc ça celui-là
l'évolution du soft power du sport
chemin que qu'au niveau des états et
donc comment voulez-vous que
1,1 cio propriétaire du olympique ait
confié des jeux à les personnes sont pas
capables de les financer de les tenir
comment on tient des jeux à les
organiser on les tient uniquement au
travers de régime qui serait
suffisamment fort ok on suffisamment je
vais dire démocratique mais qui n'ont
pas de risque majeur or aujourd'hui si
on regarde très clairement les jo ont
été attribués à pékin contre pau les
jeux d'hiver qautre kazakhstan s'était
almaty à quatre voix près des régimes
tous cas puis autoritaire donc ça
fonctionne bien et on les regarde les
requins soucisse on ferme les yeux les
ouïgours le problème de taiwan tout ça
devient secondaire pouvant que les jeux
sont organisés
on se bat pour organiser les jeux
histoire du coc vide pour tokyo ça a été
épouvantable 6 sur les collines
organiser les jeux ça a été remarquable
de leurs pas mais ils ont tout fait pour
que les jeux soient réorganisées car
s'il n'y a pas de jeu ça pose un
problème au niveau assurantiel et ainsi
de suite donc on est dans une situation
aujourd'hui qui
bon on l'a dit il faut arrêter cette
hypocrisie en disant que c'est la
politique c'est totalement politique
alors est ce que maintenant ce sont des
instruments pour préparer la guerre
c'est vrai qu'à des bruits de boîtes à
l'ukraine et tous m'ont dit les médias
disent oui oui poutine va attaquer quand
après la serbie de culture qu'on clair
je n'en sais rien quelqu'un qui fait
tout ce que je peux vous dire très
clairement ayant étudié de très près la
vie du du barreau pierre freddy de
coubertin ce brave homme
original puisqu'il soit on peut
expliquer des tas de choses le
concernant il était un admirateur de la
prusse produits pour 2 par exemple une
première il a épousé une alsacienne un
mari routard qui était alsacienne et il
a vécu très très mal son père a très mal
vécu
l'annexion de l'alsace lorraine par
bismarck et donc il a étudié de très
près la prusse il a vu que c'était
d'aider des athlètes fort costaud et
tout ça donc il fallait était grand
temps de mettre l'armée française au
rythme du sport et pour les récupérer et
à partir de là effectivement marque vous
avez raison l'aspect guerre rendent tous
genres ligne de jeu avant pendant et
après les jeux mais dès l'origine rue
des guerres commis a toujours eu des
jeux normalement forcément qu'il devait
dans l'eau la neige voilà supposer que
notre vision mois pour moi il ya trop
âgées ou alors que je vais poser
généralement en faveur du boycott et y
compris pour les raisons politiques
attaché à la nature des régimes je me
suis toujours demandé pourquoi on ne
voulait pas aller faire du sport au
moment des jeux olympiques dans tel ou
tel état selon le régime qui nous
déplaît et en même temps donc vouloir
boycotter les jeux mais pas boycotter le
commerce pas boycotter le cinéma
personne n'a dit il faut pas aller voir
deux films chinois par une personne
malade il faut pas acheter de produits
chinois quand ont boycotté les jeux les
l'afrique du sud un des seuls boycott
qui est vraiment fonctionné d'ailleurs
demandé l'apartheid ont boycotté tous
pas seulement le sport les jeux on peut
juste avant les jeux il n'avait pas bu
le sport la culture tout était boycotté
la non voudrais juste boycotter les jeux
olympiques mais continuer de vivre
normalement avec les produits chinois
parce qu'on en a besoin je ne vois pas
où il rapporte pourquoi plus pourquoi
c'est si important d'aller faut pas
aller courir chez eux il faut mais ils
peuvent convenir courir chez nous et on
populaire de manger leurs produits
ouais enfin si vous les jeux olympiques
sont un moment clé quoi voilà sans un
moment clé dans le dans comment dire
dans la diplomatie dans le dans
l'organisation disons des pays entre eux
et
parce que tout le monde y est c'est plus
voilà et représailles vous au droit et
représentent voilà enfin on se croise un
petit tour le haut un qui ont envoyé bon
qui ont cédé athlètes souvent les
professionnels bon voilà c'est pas la
jeunesse du monde la jeunesse du monde
bon allez peu là-bas c'est
essentiellement évidemment des athlètes
qui sont qui sont là-bas rebonds et
c'est vrai qu'elles représentent les
jeux olympiques représentent un moment
alors pour l analyse et plus précisément
il représente un élément incroyablement
puissant du fait justement
qu'ils sont médiatisés je pense même
plus que ça si vous voulez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les jeux olympiques ne
sont plus médiatisés mais ils sont un
média pratiquement à part entière ils
sont un média à part entière et de ce
point de vue là du point de vue vous
voyez de la diffusion qu'il représente
du poids en quelque sorte qu'ils
représentent ces trois à quatre
milliards en face c'était les choses
changent c'était 3 4 milliards
d'individus qui regardaient le les les
jeux olympiques donc pour les nations on
confond toujours le fait que trois ou
quatre milliards d'individus plus
regarder les jeux olympiques dont
reçoivent les jeux ça veut pas dire
qu'ils les regardent quentovic un
milliard de gens ont regardé le mariage
de du prince il retient qu'elle marque
elle non vous regarder mais ni vous ni
moi n'avons regarder si contents de les
comptabiliser ce si on regarde pour
regarder les jeux olympiques sont
incroyablement regard est plus que les
coupes du monde de football bon voilà
donc une espèce de comment dire de
concentration si je peux dire visuel
voyez
par le média télévisuel évidemment avait
pas évidemment la radio la presse en
parle en permanence d'aiguillés une
médaille
voilà un autre français a eu la médaille
d'or etc donc il ya vraiment les jeux
olympiques sont vraiment une espèce de
de concentrer voiliers de de la
puissance en quelque sorte de l'image à
travers le à travers le champion et donc
c'est vrai que il ya là il ya là quelque
chose de
fondamental de très important a en
quelque sorte ils participent participer
1 et il ya une espèce de consensus c'est
vrai entre les états nations pour pourri
pour une participer parce que et là on
rentre vraiment dans le débat je pense
de notre affaire parce que tout
simplement
les champions sont censés représenter si
vous voulez notre notre pays notre
nation moi je pense il voulait que les
champions comme on dit nos athlètes et
c'est moi je me reconnais pas vraiment
voilà s'impose d'abord
l'aspect de l'aspect de nos champions de
nos français qui sont les ambassadeurs
faisant alors que la foule a fait du
sport la magie etc etc il faut il
regarder quand même d'un tout petit peu
plus près je pense qu'il ya là vraiment
beaucoup de choses à dire en particulier
par rapport médical du camp fait un peu
de tout de suite et on va aller dire
juste après
[Musique]
quels sont les sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité économique des derniers
jours a tout d'abord la dette américaine
moi je suis pas d'accord pour crier au
loup sur la dette publique tout
simplement parce que quand la dette
publique arrive à échéance l'état peut
toujours et emprunter la question étant
de savoir la dette ces drapeaux futur
c'est un moment où vous apportera la
note quoi qu'il arrive donc on peut pas
dire on s'en fout toutes les banques
centrales et c'est un de juguler
l'inflation pendant que christine
lagarde qui est plutôt optimiste elle je
dis souvent que j'aimerai pas être un
banquier central en ce moment pour une
raison simple c'est que vous disposez
pas en tant que banque centrale des
instruments qui sont nécessaires à
juguler l'inflation on a aujourd'hui
c'est du discours c'est de la com
attendez que le marché est un peu secoué
et vous verrez les banquiers centraux
revenir ventre à terre en disant ah
maintenant on est désolé on revêt ce les
taux
[Musique]
sur quarante cinq pays d'afrique
subsaharienne 28 interdisent on réprime
l'homosexualité est globalement vous
observez une violence d'état bien
orchestrée à l'encontre de la communauté
lgbt sur le continent oui bien sûr sur
le plan politique ce lait d'amande
si pendant la campagne anges et dans
l'opinion ne veulent que si vous voulez
voter pour tel ou tel candidat
eh bien il va légaliser l'homosexualité
alors là on sait qu'on peut lui faire
perdre des voix comment progresse les
droits pour les homosexuels sur le
continent il faudrait que les pays
africains sachent que ce n'est pas une
bonne heure de l'acculer à pratiquer la
discrimination à toutes ces enfants ou
alors qu'on nous dise plus que l'afrique
est la mère de nous limiter
[Musique]
faut-il boycotter les jeux de paris en
2002 24 c'est le débat de ce soir avec
marc perelman l'auteur du livre 2024 les
jeux olympiques n'ont pas eu lieu aux
éditions du détour et avec armand de
rands 1 g l'auteur du livre le pari
olympiques de 2024 chance ou une
malédiction paru chez vigo alors c'est
vrai que aussi bien
l'état la france la ville de paris la
maire de paris le cio tout le monde
absolument tout le monde réclame notre
enthousiasme à l'égard de ses prochains
jeux olympiques
vous-même j'imagine à revendre ans d'âge
et battu le moment où vous aimez les
jeux olympiques vous aimé l'idée des
jeux olympiques vous pensez que c'est la
grande fête du sport à laquelle nous
faisions allusion avec marc perelman
juste avant la pause une fête de
l'amitié entre les peuples
un idéal sportif qui restent à vos yeux
j'imagine idéal abbas c'est l'idéal ça
devrait être ça ça devrait être la cible
mais malheureusement ça ne sera pas le
cas non mais c'est jamais bloquée car
c'est le cas non il faut il faut
comprendre que les jeux olympiques pour
moi qui les ai étudié puis depuis le
début qu'il y vit en régulièrement c'est
le graal des athlètes c'est vraiment
participer aux jeux olympiques et
championnats pic c'est le graal on peut
les comprendre pourquoi ça c'est
vraiment l'objectif est on verra tout à
l'heure si on ne pense aussi aux
commence à édulcorer c'était cet élément
la halle altérée je pense sera pas le
soviet des athlètes mais je pense qu'à
un moment ne les athètes boycotteront
eux directement certains s'expriment
déjà en dix ans je ne veux pas aller en
chine mais quelles sont les raisons pour
leur conscience professionnelle hiller
consente quoi leur conscience disant je
ne veux pas participer aux jeux
olympiques pour deux raisons d'une part
pour les raisons politiques qui heurte
leur conscience ça peut arriver et la
deuxième chose c'est que quand même le
sport au faux sur le fair play et sur
l'universalisme et puis repose aussi sur
l'équité de la crédibilité la légitimité
tous les scandales actuellement a que
deux pages et même les résultats mais
manipuler pose problème à des athlètes
mais ils sont encore minoritaires mais
je pense que ça ira assez vite parce que
les gens qui financent le sport est en
progrès l'occurrence l'olympisme et et
les jeux olympiques regarde de très près
tout ce caractère éthique
liés aux résultats sportifs et à la télé
d après ce qu il faut que le public soit
content
loin allons plus loin maintenant à votre
question des jeux olympiques où il n'y a
pas de population mobilisation populaire
ce ne sont pas des jeux olympiques ça
peut pas marcher c'est compliqué la
mobilisation on peut faire un référendum
il sera négatif on ne fait jamais les
falashas corde à faire affaire un homme
les gens ont dit non donc on ne fait pas
le référendum alors on invente toute une
série de choses c'est assez importante
de montrer très clairement que
l'olympisme va révolutionner la france
donc les français vont se mobiliser
derrière au travers de tout ce qu'on
fait au travers des monuments au travers
les infrastructures au travers des
promesses qui vont être donnés pour que
ce soit la fête
mais est ce que ce sera la fête ou pas
vu que pour que ce soit la fête il faut
que ça quelque chose assez spectaculaire
et c'est vrai que au niveau de paris
2024 ils sont assez créatif est assez
inédit la service d'ouverture qui est
prévu extraordinaire sur la seine ou
beyond qu'ovide oublions la sécurité
oublie que ça peut être un peu compliqué
à
gérer complètement oublié ou même le
coup que ça peut représenter le quoi
qu'il en coûte olympiques ça va venir la
surface aussi un moment ou à un autre
donc moi faire des promesses des
promesses des promesses si elles sont
pas financés va poser un gros problème
c'est est-ce que c'est comme ça que l'on
mobilise la population je n'en suis pas
persuadé je crois qu'il ya d'autres
artifices qu'il faut trouver pour que
les jeux soient une réussite et puis les
jeux sont une réussite si effectivement
on obtient des médailles le fait
d'obtenir des médailles venez déjà et
viable qui a fait venir corrosion
condition est là aujourd'hui ah
qu'est-ce qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement on a un comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques
présidée par estanguet qui doit
organiser les jeux c'est la règle
responsable à un coût 10 2 7 milliards
grosso modo et pas plus mais enfin quand
ils se sont attribués d'autres fonctions
c'est de réaliser complètement la france
les territoires c'est pudiquement paris
on va même jusqu'à la tahiti pour le
surf et en levant et d'ailleurs c'est
normal ça de vendre le passage de la
flamme olympique 180000 euros au
département abbas et le savait que rien
n'ait été grattée bien mairie alors de
l'atome et un koala alors moi j'ai pas
fais partie à des histoires de montage
de parcours de la flamme olympique c'est
une cash machine extraordinaire mais
sont fait payer les états ont fait payer
les villes et tout se mêle ça aussi il
ya aussi des gens qui ont payé par
exemple des pays ou des états ou des
communes ou des rues ou des commerçants
ont payé le passage de religieux dans
leur rue pour denis certaines valeurs où
ça existe partout et là il ya une petite
assimilation peut-être entre l'olympisme
et la religion
cette grande fête du sport et de
l'amitié entre les peuples en fait c'est
d'abord une compétition qui fabrique
du
racisme de la violence du sexisme vu que
les hommes et les femmes sont pas
ensemble et puis que les hommes battrait
les femmes si donc tout est donc très
sexy de l'homophobie
des inégalités puisque il y en a qui
gagnent des médailles et d'autres pas
malheur au vaincu voilà donc pour eux
c'est pas la fête du tout c'est la fête
pour celui qui gagne très peu finalement
de gens pour le pour les autres c'est la
défaite
ça monte ça monte oui ça monte à à
l'essence même de l'olympisme et du fort
reconnaissez-le celle du sport du sport
au 19e siècle du sport de compétition
tel qu'on le connaît tales qui se
développe depuis depuis depuis oui
depuis coubertin en gros est peut-être
un petit peu un petit peu avant l'armée
mais ça vient de coubertin quand vous
lisez coubertin
qui est un grand humaniste bon état des
propos colonialiste il a des propos
racistes et même découvert je croyais
pas mais même des propos antisémites un
bon voilà mais c'est l'idéal si vous
voulez c'est l'idéal de quoi c'est
l'idéal de l'homme fort voilà avec les
nazis c'est à dire jusqu'à la belle
belle brune blonde mais pour coubertin
c'est ça c'est quand même l'homme
performant lui été contraint ce qu'ils
apprennent les olobe performance est
normal que ceux qui aiment le sport
révèle que les hommes soient performants
ça paraît logique c'est une certaine
c'est une certaine logique mais si vous
laissez l'idéal voilà c'est l'idéal de
la performance c'est l'idéal du de
l'homme parfait du corps musclé c'est
cet idéal ciblées qui pour moi
m'inquiète quand même un exemple quand
vous dites ça fabrique du racisme
pourquoi parce qu'a priori justement
tout le monde d'accord avec tout le
monde
oui enfin un court court avec tout le
monde c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça
fabrique du racisme vous voyez part donc
sur les terrains de football
dans les tribunes où il ya des propos
racistes homophobes régulier
et et c est si vous voulez le racisme
oui ça déforme disons de raciste dans le
sens où tout d'un coup c'est vrai on l'a
vu par exemple à la finale de mexico en
68 la finale du 100 m c'est vrai la
finale du 100 m était uniquement noir je
pense que s'ils voulaient le racisme
commence là le racisme qui commence là
parce que voilà les jeux qui se
prétendent être des jeux universel il y
ait des jeux où tout le monde doit
pouvoir participer eh bien on s'aperçoit
en fait que voilà selon les compétences
selon l'orientation qui est proposé est
bien on voit voilà si je peux dire des
couleurs se mettre plus en avant aussi
je peux dire que
que dorothée donc c'est vrai qu'à d'une
certaine façon les jeux olympiques
fabrique de la discrimination fabrique
d'abord la discrimination sexuelle
on dit que non mais si justement les
jeux olympiques se fonde sur la
discrimination entre hommes et femmes je
crois qu'il ya quatre ou cinq pour cent
des preuves il ya une réelle mixité bord
c'est la base musculaire n'est pas la
même chose allez on va donc six mois y
est voilà la compétition c'est
exactement ce que j'essaie de vous dire
la compétition la compétition sportive
d'emblée d'emblée écarté a dit on sépare
hommes et femmes or précisément si
voulez moi je suis un humaniste et 13
points de vue là moi je pense que la
fête la fête où le sport ou plus présent
moi je définirais plutôt le jeu s'est
pas vraiment des jeux olympiques
inception de sports olympiques le jeu
celle inverse c'est précisément la
mixité c'est à dire vraiment voilà on
est ensemble hommes et femmes pour faire
les activités physiques que l'on
souhaite c'est la gratuité c'est la
spontanéité dans les jeux olympiques
c'est tout sauf ça tout est donc
effectivement la première chose c'est la
séparation des hommes et des femmes
parce qu'effectivement comme vous le
disiez les hommes sur tous les terrains
sont les plus forts
alors là c'est ce qui m'inquiète il
voulait c'est la revendication de
certaines féministes qui nous disent il
faut qu'il y ait plus de femmes qu'il
faut y ait des femmes qui soient aux
jeux olympiques parce que dans ce cas là
on pourra
à être à égalité avec les hommes elles
se rendent pas compte que c'est une
fausse égalité c'est une fausse symétrie
ont fait perdurer en fait cette
séparation des hommes et des femmes où
l'homme le bel athlète hommes restent
fondamentalement le vrai sportif le vrai
celui qui qui qui qui est dépositaire de
2,2 de la performance moi et c'est ça
moi qui me met que je trouve enfin c'est
un des aspects disons de l'olympisme qui
me qui m'inquiète c'est cet aspect là
c'est tout d'un coup c'est cette idée si
vous voulez que on nous dit que c'est la
réunion de la jeunesse et cetera non
c'est une séparation entre la la
jeunesse en général c'est des millions
des millions d'individus et une jeunesse
professionnelle et une jeunesse
là dessus on s'entendra peut être pas
non plus être nos collègues mais c'est
une jeunesse qui est quand même pour
l'essentiel dopé je suis un pic c'est un
vaste entrepôt c'est un vaste entrepôt
de dopage
vous avez par exemple la fédération de
russie aujourd'hui qui n'est plus
admises aux jeux olympiques parce que il
ya eu un taux page d'état un dopage
d'état qui fait que les athlètes russes
ne peuvent plus concourir sous leurs
sous leur drapeau et concourt sous le
drapeau sous drapeau olympique mais on
apprend régulièrement régulièrement que
tel athlète s'est dopé aux olympiques de
pékin aux jeux olympiques de londres et
c'est rsa le co2 ne sait même plus à qui
donnait d'ailleurs les médailles
tellement nombre de doper souvenez-vous
1 marion jones affichant nord des états
unis doper son mari dopé l'un sur le
point et caetera et c'est ce que je
pense aujourd'hui s'ils voulaient des
jeux olympiques c'est que le dopage
aujourd'hui c'est une fausse course 1
que le cio tente de mener disons contre
le dopage ils savent pertinemment que
les dopés on j'allais dire un couloir où
une longueur d'avancé à chaque fois
c'est une fausse course mans je pense
que si vous voulez aujourd'hui les jeux
olympiques c'est le lieu du dopage c'est
le lieu de l'expérimentation du dopage
et que cette idée de nous faire croire
qu'on va lutter conte lutte contre c'est
évidemment une pure illusion aujourd'hui
non le dopage est centrale dans le jeux
olympiques il fait partie il est
pourrait dire consubstantiel même à
l'olympie ce à moindre en ag oui il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites par
joseph par marc jeu
tous pourris ça je n'y crois pas
première chose deuxième chose faire ou
dire que je ne reviendrai pas à la
pensée de coubertin à l'eau de ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui revisiter
l'histoire toujours compliqué le côté
réactionnaire misogyne antisémite
colonialiste et ainsi de suite je l'ebit
bien vécu il existe est véritablement
chez coubertin c'est vrai mais il était
exactement dans l'ambiance de l'époque
je suis tellement dans la sphère de
répondre et fussent ils s'est pas mêlée
il n'a pas voulu ni pour ni contre bon
il avait une admiration devant les états
autoritaires première chose deuxième
chose il était complètement bercé par
une chose et là vous avez raison mais
les conséquences sont pas celles là
c'est que lui il trouvait que le sport
sans compétition n'avait pas de
signification l'activité physique qui
était entretenue par les républicains de
l'époque bon c'était la gymnastique
points de plus et 10 et l'homme doit
tous devraient s'affronter dans le cadre
d'une compétition alors on est pour ou
on est contre le sport maurice barrès
disais que ça a créé le sport créé des
ignares des cardiaques des éclopés et
puis je suis plus les abrutis chez plus
également le dernier terme mais
il faut bien comprendre
la philosophie des jeux olympiques à
partir de coubertin et on oubliera
couverte et ensuite c'est la compétition
alors la compétition bien sûr je les lui
dans votre ouvrage pour vous c'est le
fruit de damnés de capitalisme repeint
qui a entraîné la compétition existe
elle est naturelle pour coubertin le
micro on n'y croit pas ses deuxièmes
deuxièmement
la la grande difficulté qu'a aujourd'hui
le mouvement olympique c'est qu'il est à
la fois juge et partie sur le dopage
marclay tout à fait raison
je luttons contre le dopage mais pour
masquer le dopage et les gens ont eu un
couloir des années d'avant ce1 on se
dope mais on prend les produits aussi
pour cacher le dopage mais aussi tout le
monde y trouve son compte et dopage mais
tous
les autres aussi nommé l'histoire de la
russie c'est absolument incroyable c'est
un dopage d'état bon on a admis sous la
bannière olympique quelques athlètes
c'est tout là il ya une athlète aux jeux
de pékin à la petite qui a 15 ans qu'ils
considéraient comme dopés on lui permet
de me le permet de continuer parce que
le voisin russe qui finance va poser un
problème donc tant que c'est les lirez
tant que le seuil haut le mouvement
olympique au traversions tribunal du
sport
il a créé un écosystème où le droit est
assumée pas l'écosystème lui-même à
partir de là toutes les dérives sont
possibles et là je comprends
parfaitement bien les critiques de
marque complètement mais est ce que pour
cela il faut abandonner cette espèce
deux
organisations de tous les quatre ans qui
est vraiment le graal de plus à l'écouté
vous enlevez aussi la coupe du monde des
nations moi je pense qu'il faut pas
qu'il faut pas le faire voler un jour
bien simple ce que moi au début de mon
reportage je suis confiant sur la
réaction des athlètes où est ce que je
veux dire djokovic qu'une fois ma tasse
de thé a dit moi je veux pas me faire
vacciner donc j'ignore bages d'accord je
quitte l'australie je ferai pas ça aux
bordelaises garros donc vous avez un
mouvement chez les apps est aujourd'hui
pour considérer que bon très très bien
nous appartenons à nos fédérations c'est
les fédérations les comités olympiques
qui nous sélectionne poli jeux
olympiques mais nous nous souhaitons
participer à la gestion de tout cet
ensemble là parce que la raison des deux
jeux olympiques ce sont les appétits
rien d'autre ok bah voilà partir de là
si on va vers ses tendances et on va y
aller j'espère que rapidement on pourra
très certainement retirée tout petit
même bible ce sont les athlètes à
l'origine le festival de cannes c'est lé
pays oui qui choisissaient les films
qu'ils allaient envoyer au festival de
cannes comme aujourd'hui ce sont les
pays qu'ils choisissent les athlètes qui
vont envoyer un pic à monde a fait la
révolution on a dit ça suffit maintenant
c'est le festival de cannes qui va
choisir les films et puis vous allez
arrêtez vous les états d'âme c'est quand
même au début ont joué l'hymne national
comme et bien c'est n'importe quoi est
exactement comme jeux olympiques
pourquoi est ce que les jeux olympiques
ne pourrait pas être puisque le cio
fettouhi pourrait aussi sélectionner les
athlètes y remédier il et sélectionne
indirectement par le sait comité
national pis que le comité national et
sportif français il n'a aucun moyen
financier parce qu'on est dans un
communiqué le gouverneur français très
très original contrairement à l'italie
ou subissent ministère des sports et
puis comité national b sont mêlés c'est
le comité national olympique qui est le
bras armé entre guillemets du cio qui
sélectionne les athlètes les fédérations
proposent dit voilà je propose tel
athlète ok c'est le séno bien sûr donc
c'est le celi peau il s'arrête de
défiler derrière un drapeau qu'on arrête
ces images soient l'aria au titre
personnel vous avez pu surtout que les
états arrête de compter les médailles en
faisant fi de l'importance de leur bonne
foi mais les trois plus gros pays
bullseye parfaitement rien le plus de
bébés est surtout fier alors que ceux ci
ont divisé par le nombre d'habitants il
aurait pas
et encore plus si longtemps ont tempéré
ça avec le pib fait suffisamment les
pays riches ont plus de médailles que
les pays et vous avez on entretient donc
le chauvinisme sportif de la scène annie
et autres condamnations et c'est
totalement absurde voilà ce qui est
différent d'ailleurs de ce qui est
indiqué dans la charte olympique dans la
charte olympique qui a pas de défilé des
nations à ce qu'on appelle la parade des
nations d'ailleurs un qui a été inventé
en 1928 amsterdam ce défilé derrière son
drapeau nation mais dans la charte
olympique ne veut pas on n'en parle pas
du tout il n'y a jamais le mot nation
qui est qui est indiquée donc là aussi
ça a été ça a été une décision du du du
cio de la même façon ce que que le
nombre de médailles
médailles le tableau des médailles 1 ça
aussi c'est une invention du cio vous ne
trouvez pas du tout dans la dans l'achat
de tables
d'hôtes et par pays par pays et pour les
pays pour les états nations c'est vrai
que c'est fondamental de se retrouver en
tête 1 pour la chine évidemment pour la
russie pour les états unis d'être le
plus médaillé d'or c'est
qu'on peut pas être les plus nombreux
puisque on est un petit pays par rapport
à un bon c'est une entrave ses députés
c'est contre tout ça si vous voulez que
mes jeux revue que je refuse voyez
depuis que je que je réfute complètement
parce que si vous voulez il ya une
espèce de délire nationaliste avec ça
alors on pourrait nous dire on pourrait
nous dire voilà ça ne pourrait être que
des athlètes mais c'est pas possible le
monde était organisée de telle façon que
ce sont les états nations qui décide pas
complètement c'est vrai que celle-ci ou
qui décide voilà mais on ne défile
ravagea ne se sont se sont vraiment des
dpi voyez qu'ils sont qui sont comme dit
reporter en quelque sorte voiliers de de
la valeur en quelque sorte olympique
donc pour tous les pays il est
fondamental de savoir que on a un
médaillé olympique vous voyez par
exemple le slalom là qui vient d'être
gagnée par un français immédiatement le
figaro le monde etc vous avez le nom du
du vainqueur dont il ya une espèce si
vous venez de deux volontés des
états-nations par chauvinisme par
nationalisme et qui est fondamentalement
lié si vous voulez pour moi à la
compétition sportive il n'ya de
compétition sportif dès lors qui dès
lors qu'il ya compétition entre entre
nations entre athlètes certes mais mais
entre entre nations voilà qui sont
aujourd'hui la manière dont était tout
simplement être organisé le monde voit
l'annoncé contre ça évidemment que moi
je l'appelle j'appelle effectivement à
boycotter les jeux olympiques parce que
on a là on a là une espèce de fièvre si
vous les nationalistes sont alors de ce
nationalisme que aujourd'hui commence à
y avoir et je crois que vous vous le dit
aussi perelman qu'on se plaint du
désastre écologique que pourraient être
les jeux olympiques de paris en 2024 la
seine-saint-denis s'en plaint beaucoup
il ya des jardins qui sont détruits
bétonné chaque jeux olympiques chaque
jeux olympiques est une reconfiguration
du paysage on l'avait vu par an pour
sotchi où là le paysage disons alentours
un de sotchi était complètement
transformé des rivières détourné bon et
la transformation même de la ville
elle-même de sotchi en ce qu'elle est
devenue aujourd'hui ce tir d'une ville
une ville une ville fantôme on l'a vu
aussi pour les jeux de pékin en 2008 où
les lélés le disons le le lait la ville
le noyau urbain les ce qu'on appelle les
routes ont été détruits pour pour
reconstruire des des stades qui est
l'eau ni un le nid d'oiseau qui as 4 et
qui ne sert pas aujourd'hui voilà à
chaque fois c'est la transformation
territoriale urbaine voiliers du pays et
c'est ce qu'on veut pour la france le
coup effectivement il est patent sur les
sites un an nous raconter c'est vrai
c'est 90 92 % cadre à 15 % des sites qui
sont déjà à peu près c'est le
chamboulement territoriale qu'imposent
les jeux olympiques c'est cette année
avant si vous voulez paris l'île de
france sont dans un chamboulement urbain
absolument complet avec des gars
soixantaine de gares qui sont installés
avec une spéculation immobilière
incroyable
bouygues véolia et autres se gavent
quand vous leur parler parce que tout
d'un coup il va ya voir voilà des
champignons autour des gares de villes
qui vont ceux qui vont ceux qui vont
chanter plus le plus le transport la
métropole qu'on est en train de
construire à cause des jeux olympiques
il est une métropole c'est vrai de
grande circulation avec avec encore une
fois des points des pointes de création
de garde très très important très très
lourd et donc une volonté de encore une
fois de faire circuler de et de créer de
la cré de la circulation c'est ça qui la
grande culture c'est ce que ça crée de
la beauté la beauté qui n'existaient pas
ou est ce que yakin aux importants que
vous oubliez sans doute marge de dire
c'est pas les jeux olympiques ont soit
la compétition c'est
l'institution comité international
olympique lorsque en 2013 ils ont
d'ailleurs 2013 de lancer l'appel
l'agenda 20 20
il ya eu deux révolutions a pas
aujourd'hui coubertin il ya eu la
révolution samaranch en 1981
le mouvement olympique le jeux
olympiques étaient totalement exsangues
samaranch a dit je fais rentrer les
professionnels et le marketing ça a été
une inflation un
incroyable au point de l'argent à une
orgie de rentrées d'argent et tout ça ça
c'était la première à la première
évolution 80 et tous les effets que ses
yeux toutes les candidatures tous les
pays qui voulaient organiser les jeux la
deuxième révolution c'est celle de
thomas sba 2013 lorsqu'il a inventé la
jada 20 en dix ans les jeux olympiques
ne peut plus être cette petite
compétition qui ils eurent quinze jours
il faut que ce soit totalement intégré
dans la politique nationale territoriale
du pays dont vous faites en sorte que
l'olympisme les jeux olympiques sim ici
ainsi je peux dire c'est un style dans
tous les mails et les éléments les
monuments les quartiers les gares les
transports et ça c'est une véritable
révolution
et marc permet non seulement je le
montre bien que on n'a pas bien perçu en
france on est à chic c'est très bien
comme ça ça rentre dans mon programme
politique et ainsi de suite mais les
conséquences sont énormes c'est qu'on
aura olympique et si je peux dire en
bien ou en mal avec une chance ou avec
malédiction en beaucoup moins beau ça
chacun jugera à l'arrivée mais c'est
clair que c'est une transformation
radicale non seulement du sport mais
c'est devant aurillac de la ville ce
sont les lois alors je vais plus loin ce
qu'il veut beaucoup plus c'est que la
transformation de la ville savez quand
vous lancez un nucléaire là vous n'êtes
pas débité 10 ans de retard pour va
c'est grave on a des déficits et tous
les jeux olympiques peut pas permettre
d'avoir une seconde de retard d'une
seconde de retard vous payez les
millions de pénalités
tour pour la met en place en plus une
loi bon que mark ne dirais pas
liberticide en quelque sorte en disant
oui on a une loi olympique d'exception
pour faire en sorte que les appels
d'offres tout ça ça passe plus vite
possible et qu on respecte les chairs en
ce qu'il faut et dans un délai très
court on va transformer complètement la
ville est ce que on va la transformer en
bien est ce que c'est vrai pour être
supportable d'appoint du financier point
d'interrogation point d'interrogation là
on s'écarte des jeux olympiques pour
préparer non non je pense qu'on est au
coeur des jeux olympiques juste très
bien qu'on se demandait justement au
coeur des jeux olympiques parce
qu'effectivement les olympiques
deviennent de plus en plus si vous
voulez la volonté de transformer voyez
les métropoles de transformer le
caractère disons urbain etc il ya avec
la loi olympiques et paralympiques a un
qui a été voté un accès doit lire dans
un consensus c'est une loi d'exception
où la souveraineté de l'état et tout
d'un coup le v1 complètement donc le cio
peut décider et décide un que versailles
l'arc de triomphe la tour eiffel etc
seront enveloppé du drapeau olympique
avec coca cola alibaba et ses à-côtés
bon est ce que c'est ça la nouvelle
esthétique
cristaux
le cio voyez c c'est quand même faut pas
l'oublier
anisation internationale non
gouvernementale à but non lucratif bon
nom générale plié en 4 contre quand on
finit de le dire bon ils prennent
possession de la ville ils prennent
possession de la villa ils la prennent
possession c'est vrai pendant 15 jours
puis quinze jours pour les paralympiques
ils prennent vraiment possession de la
ville par la manière si vous voulez
d'imposer d'imposer une vision urbaine
de la ville qu'il a effectivement on l'a
vu on voit
actuellement un pari est totalement
transformé avec des travaux gigantesques
la seine saint denis est elle-même aussi
le lieu voyait de transformation assez
un assez importante et puis d'une
manière beaucoup plus générale l'île de
france et transformé donc pour pas avoir
du tout comme quelque chose voilà qui se
résume à gracc un jour non pas du tout
c'est sûr des années que le cio impose
son diktat et pas simplement un diktat
civil et de compétition mais aussi un
dictature ben c'est être à la celle
c'est le cas blanc pour paris avant
c'était un petit peu différent parce que
le seiu ne l'imposé pas barcelone s'est
développée par lui-même mais maintenant
dans le cas de paris paris s'est prêtée
totalement jeu pour que ce soit
transformé en parti grâce aux jeux
olympiques merci tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]